get the book the best mental math tricks
hi this is presto occur in this video
I'm going to explain how you can
remember the fractions of seven get out
six cards in order one for two eight
five and seven this is the decimal
representation of one over seven its of
these six numbers which keep repeating
over and over again one four two eight
five seven to get two over seven you
look for the second largest number which
is to have the cards in the same order
starting with the two and then rearrange
the other cards one and four to the end
and this will give you 2 over 7 which is
2 8 5 7 1 4 and it keeps repeating in
that order to get to 3 over 7 you look
for the third largest number which is 4
and we want the number 4 to start out so
we put the number four at the beginning
keep the rest of the cards in the same
order and this will be the decimal
representation of 3 over 7 which is 0.42
8 5 7 1 and then the numbers keep
repeating in that order to get to 4 over
7 we look for the fourth largest number
which is 5 we make the list of numbers
start with 5 and then we rearrange the
rest of the cards at the end
so this is 4 over 7 which is 5 7 1 4 2 8
and the numbers keep repeating in that
order we continue to get 5 over 7 it
starts out with the sudden we go 7 1 4 2
8 5 and the numbers will repeat in that
order and finally we get 6 over 7 which
starts out with the largest number 8 we
move those cards at the beginning and
append the remaining cards at the end in
the same order so 6 over 7 is 8 5 7 1 4
2 and the numbers keep repeating in that
order so as long as you remember 1 4 2 8
5 7 you can always get all the decimals
of 7 and to start all over just start
with the ACE and this brings us back to
1 over 7 which is 1 4 to 8 5 7 and the
numbers repeat in that order
I hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can get my
books listed on my website catch me on
my blog mind your decisions on Twitter
at fresh talker and you can support me
on patreon